hey there welcome to the uplift we've
got a great show for you a great cast of
characters as well as we like to say
including these a grandmother and her
grandson who went on a seven year
adventure together how he helped her
fulfill a truly epic bucket list and a
man who braved flood waters determined
to get somewhere very important where to
go we'll tell you
also a boy given 30 minutes to live yes
just 30 minutes but he overcame those
odds and just reached a very big
milestone also a farmer who got in an
accident and could no longer attend to
his own crops but his farm not forgotten
plus a man who got a second chance at
life and dedicated it all to ice cream
my kind of guy all that plus our
heartwarming videos ones you just gotta
see you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
hey there I'm Tony decopo welcome to the
uplift the show that lifts you up for at
least the next 30 minutes no
prescription required we're going to
begin with a story about a fun Duo who
went on a seven year long adventure
together here's Caitlin O'Kane with more
on what was an epic journey
When Brad Ryan decided he needed a
peaceful break he planned a road trip to
a national park rather than go alone he
thought of the perfect sidekick his
grandma Joy when I learned she'd never
seen
uh the great wildernesses of America
deserts mountains uh oceans you name it
I thought that that was something that
would haunt me if I didn't intervene in
some way well about all the traveling I
needed was a fishing hole every winter
my husband took me to Okeechobee and we
fished that was about the extent of my
wondering
after that first visit to the Great
Smoky Mountains they realized they could
continue to road trip around the U.S
hitting multiple Parks each time the
more I kept reading about the parks and
I saw how close they were to one another
that we could make this giant Loop it
became an obsession and all I could
think about was I've got to see Grandma
Joy at Old Faithful I've got us here at
the Redwoods and I've got to see her at
the Grand Canyon I just I have to do
this I have to have those those memories
for my own long-term happiness I think
we're two peas in a pod when it comes to
just our desire for travel Adventure
connection Joy is now 92. she has three
children and four grandchildren and Brad
says she can still keep up when they're
hiking mountains so what's Joy's secret
to staying active
well I guess it helps to be optimistic
and you have to have the will to do it
and I've been lucky health-wise that I'm
able to do that
for pride and joy sometimes the most
powerful moments don't happen on the
trail but in the car we hit the road
together and we start talking about our
lives and she's she told me things in
her 80s and 90s about her life some of
the difficult things she's been through
that she's never spoken to anybody in
her life and I was able to open up to
her about some of the trials and
tribulations of my own life but that's
what I think is so powerful about the
open road is that you know you only can
drive so far before those memories start
to to creep forward there are 63 U.S
national parks and they've hit 62. it's
not a specific Park that stands out to
them it its memories we went on the
Channel Islands and I got to see my
first whale and he happened to jump up
right in front of him
Grandma joy and of course you can't help
but love the Redwood Forest to think
it's still standing there that many
years just really make you feel very
tiny when you look up at the sky we just
went white water rafting at 91 class 3
Rapids she was braver than I was
that was a way of a trip I'll tell you
that
the 63rd and final Park on their list is
the national park of American Samoa
which they're planning to hit in April
it's about 6 700 miles from Ohio where
where we live it's the only U.S national
park that's south of the Equator it's
way out in the South Pacific it's a long
haul but we're excited to go after a
seven year Adventure they're ready for
their grand finale we can enjoy the
beach we can enjoy the you know the
beautiful Tropical Paradise but as We've
Come To Learn by talking to the Rangers
that work there American Samoa is an
island community that is very firmly
rooted in family
and I think that there's a bit of a
poetic
um Beauty to ending it there for that
reason as well both Brad and Joy said
their epic trip has taught them many
important lessons for one thing climb
mountains while you can another
Revelation Joy is the perfect name for
this inspiring grandmother she has
always lived from a place of gratitude
and joy and that's a choice that she
made you know that's that's um
that's a power that we all have and a
choice that we all have
and I think that that's been my greatest
lesson and um and I think that there's
really there's no end in sight for for
Grandma Joy
every morning for giving me another day
and it's your choice whether you're
going to be a grumpy day or a sunny day
so tomorrow to everybody and let
everybody know you're having a whale of
a die
that's a great Duo there if you're
struggling to find the words to say to
somebody getting a car together the
words will come love that story moving
on for now though to this one hurricane
Ian after it made landfall a man named
Johnny Lauder left home and waited a
half a mile into the storm surge why he
was on a rescue mission you could say
determined to save someone very
important Nicole Lauren from our CBS
Miami station has their story
well it was a frantic phone call from
his mother that sprung Johnny Lauder
into action he found out that the rising
water in her house was up to her chest
so he risked his own life to save her
the fight had been 20 minutes later uh
it's a bit different interview
did image be
yond the world 84 year old Karen Lauder
in chess deep water inside of her Naples
home confined to a wheelchair get four
feet of water
and I've been swimming forever flood
waters are rising and the clock is
ticking so her son Johnny did the
unthinkable the 49 year old climbed out
of his window battled the current and
swam to his mother's house I don't know
what time it is 3 41
. what's typically a 10-minute walk was
a nearly one hour Journey it doesn't
look like waves it looks like the Earth
is moving and things above the water are
standing still along the way he found
things like a life jacket and a
kneeboard items he used to stay afloat
and when he finally made it to his
mother's house he sent his family this
video to show they were both alive with
my mom I got her up on the table wrapped
up so she doesn't go into hypothermia
she only has one leg so it's going to be
very difficult trying to get out of here
you can see the water outside is still
up to the window shortly after lauder's
son came to help
all three made the Trek home a
wheelchair half deep water
uh yeah that's done now today the Lotter
family is reflecting and this image is
one they will never forget you know so
much other stuff happening right now and
I feel I'm not important but I guess
they want to see that there is some
Humanity left so and as far as Karen
goes I'm Nicole nice to meet you she's
at a local hospital being treated for an
infection she says she's doing okay I
look I hold on to the kitchen table and
looked out the window and I seen all the
water
I couldn't believe it your son's a great
guy you raised a good one so we're just
happy you're safe
you can't tell him that he might get a
big head
and when it comes to evacuating Karen
says she is never riding out a storm
again get to another place I uh and
there's another hurricane coming through
You're darn shooting I'm going to the
shelter now Karen and the rest of the
family seem to be keeping their spirits
up with a good sense of humor they also
added that everything that was ruined
during the storm is just material and
can be replaced they're just grateful to
be alive in Naples Nicole Lauren CBS 4
News
all right coming up after a terrible
accident a farmer had to leave his crops
behind but his farm was not ignored what
happened to keep them in business and
the baby given 30 minutes to live more
than two years later he's hitting a
major milestone in his journey
[Music]
welcome back to the uplift we bring you
back with some soft guitar because we've
got those heartwarming videos ones you
just gotta see and we're going to begin
with this one take a gander at your
screen that's two-year-old Liam joining
his big sister's cheer squad they're on
the sidelines of course and you can see
that toddler knows the routine knows it
really well performs it with Precision
mom says that's because he has spent a
lot of time with those games watching
his sister practice not only there but
also in their living room it's got a
bright future ahead look at those moves
all right to our next video Toby the
rescue dog there he is celebrated his
birthday recently and the party went
viral Toby was found by the side of the
road last year and adopted by a loving
and caring family a dream of every dog
and told us that he turned two this year
Toby didn't say that the family did but
this was like his first birthday because
he never had a celebration before
remember he was a rescue that's before
he was found now he's in what they call
his forever home oh look at the little
cake it's made to look like a phone I
love it all right we got one more story
for you take a look at this video it's
from a kindergartner kindergarten
teacher her name is Miss Phillips she
goes by cool Miss p
IC what'd you say it loud
come on
that's what I'm talking about go come on
man I am smart yeah you won come on girl
I love it yeah you are Bella Grill
I can control my own feelings
yes you are
[Music]
that I can do anything
I can do hard things
I can do anything
[Music]
I believe in me the kids are gonna
remember cool Mrs P and I think you will
too if you'd like to watch more of our
heartwarming videos you can find them on
Facebook that's facebook.com uplift news
coming up in just a moment when a
two-year-old is given just one wish what
does she choose something that can
benefit other kids imagine that and he
bought a boat off of Craigslist but he
had no clue that this particular boat
was the inspiration behind a TV show one
guess two guesses come on we'll tell you
after the break
[Music]
when a farmer in Minnesota got to a
serious accident he had to leave his
farm for weeks but during his recovery
his crops were not forgotten here CBS
Minnesota's John lordson
never been worried through the whole
thing because the good Lord usually
takes care of me one way or the other on
August 15th Scott legrid was driving to
do some work at a gravel pit when a dog
ran into the road he swerved quickly
lost control and ended up rolling his
truck several times broken right
collarbone
punctured and collapsed right lung seven
broken ribs on the left side those were
just some of his injuries he spent weeks
recovering at the Mayo Clinic but while
he was rehabbing his neighbors were
plotting after the Saint Peter tornado
he was up there after the flooding in
Grand Forks or he was up there and
helped fellow farmer Tim steyer has
always admired Scott's willingness to
volunteer so Tim and other Farmers
decided to do something special for
their neighbor were you surprised that
so many people wanted to step up to help
Scott no not a bit this this is Farm
country the generosity started right
away right away on Tuesday neighbors
showed up with combines trucks and green
carts and made fast work of Scott's
soybeans they harvested about 240 acres
in about four hours that would have
taken Scott a week to do on his own what
made it even more special is they did
the exact same thing for Scott 11 years
ago after his dad passed away from
Kansas sir it's pretty amazing you know
these people are taking time out of
their busy schedule this is a busy time
of the year for us Farmers a patience
plays a big part Faith plays a big part
in getting through something like this
in Faribault County John lordson WCCO 4
News
Community coming to the Rescue out there
I love that story moving on to our next
Chris Wilson he bought an old boat
docked in California and he was
determined to save it what he didn't
know was he was renovating the
inspiration behind a nautical TV show
your CBS Sacramento is Steve large
this is the original love bow its days
are now spent docked in the San Joaquin
Delta undergoing a massive renovation I
decided I needed to do what I could to
try to you know save the ship Chris
Wilson bought the boat off Craigslist
and only later found its history the
ship inspiring The Love Boat author to
write the book that became the series
and she was a cruise director aboard
this vessel for quite some time Wilson
gave us a tour inside where you could
feel the ship's history and this is kind
of uh what you'd call the grand
staircase the main Lounge has chairs and
tables that were on the original Love
Boat series along with artwork from the
show hey let's go ahead and take a look
at something exciting and new on this
old Love Boat one of the rooms opened
the door and step inside the ship has
130 rooms and when it was in its Heyday
could hold 230 passengers and 35 crew
here's a photo of the ship in the 1960s
taken at a port in Greece and a model of
what it will look like when the
renovation is complete this Love Boat TV
show reboot I absolutely think that that
this thing's gonna you know play some
kind of a role in that how could it not
turns out the boat that launched the
brand is in our Delta backyard
the things you find on Craigslist love
that renovation expert all right here we
go uh to our next story if you give a
two-year-old a wish
what are they going to ask for well one
little girl in Minnesota wished for
something very simple but it ended up
benefiting a lot of other kids here at
CBS Minnesota's Ren Clayton
[Applause]
Joy comes in many forms
complain it came as a carnival
for two-year-old Kenna Volkman she had
one wish
thanks to fridley-based wishes and more
that came true
about a year and a half ago Kenna was
diagnosed with retinoblastoma she had a
tumor on her left eye at first it was it
was very scary and then as as it came to
the point where the chemo was done it
became more just looking forward to the
future and at this point we're we're in
maintenance mode and we're hoping that
it continues that way Kenna has had two
more tumors quickly treated she now has
partial Vision in that one eye it's
stressful
Saturday a celebration of the progress
she's made but she had one more wish
oh this is Kenna's family wanted the
carnival to help Grant even more kids
wishes doing double duty as a fundraiser
touched all of our hearts because it was
to give at the same time having
experience for a little girl who loves
parties we invited everyone we know so
friends from work friends of daycare
friends all around everyone
hundreds of people came through Infinite
Campus in Blaine to lend their support
for an organization who grants wishes as
big as deep sea fishing or Disneyland
trips for kids who are sick we come in
and can't do anything about that but we
sure can make some very special memories
and some extraordinary moments and
that's what we do her family will
remember this day forever this weekend a
unique wish granted
jumping for joy in Blaine Wren Clayton
WCCO 4 News
coming up in just a moment a man who got
into a biking accident dealt with
serious pain then used his second chance
at life for something sweet
plus after 1 000 days in the hospital
this baby has reached a happy Milestone
meets the inspiring two-year-old it's up
next
[Music]
Francisco spent the first thousand days
of his life in the hospital but
overcoming many challenges after he did
so he had a life-changing Milestone
here's CBS Chicago's Sharde Gray
Francesco Bruno will be three in
December he has seen nothing but
Hospital walls his whole life relying on
a ventilator to breathe
and tubes that help him eat but on
Tuesday that all changes we're very
happy excited uh nervous tense scared
and overwhelmed really happy everything
all together Overjoyed it's just a
Melting Pot of emotions he has a
life-threatening genetic condition that
affects his bones and muscles Francesco
was diagnosed with a rare form of
skeletal dysplasia that specifically
impacts his ribs making it difficult for
his lungs to grow properly but his
parents say he's a fighter they told us
when he was going to be born he was only
going to live for 30 minutes you know so
I mean this it's really a miracle that
he's with us today Francesco has been to
four different hospitals in three
different states and today he gets to go
home to be with his family it's not only
emotional for his parents but for the
staff at Lara beta hospital as well
Francesco home won't be without
challenges but Hospital staff say he is
getting stronger every day and his
parents took classes and are trained to
handle his many needs the day that he
first got admitted here those
conversations were starting to happen
between our case management and our
nursing team to get them ready and
prepared we're gonna start with this one
day at a time like we've been doing
chartier gray CBS 2 News
[Music]
finally a man who got into an accident
got a second chance at life and then
dedicated that second chance to ice
cream here's Omar via Franco with the
story
it's delivery day for will Gibson and
his canine co-pilot together they
deliver homemade ice cream and sweet
greetings who wouldn't want to buy
something that tastes amazing and you
know that you're supporting someone
behind it the person behind it is a
former home theater salesman now ice
cream entrepreneur a career change
forced by a bicycle crash that left
Gibson in severe pain and unable to work
making ice cream at home started as a
hobby to keep him busy and evolved into
a business gorgeous now Gibson turns out
600 pints a week when you were in the
hospital did you think that there was
light at the end of this tunnel no no
ice cream rescued Gibson and his rescue
dog has become the name and face of his
company Sweet Pearl she showed up
abandoned on his doorstep while he was
recovering Pearl and I had each other
I'm probably going to be suffering to
some degree for the rest of my life but
all of this is worth it a business
changing lives one scoop at a time white
chocolate and churro coffee it is my
absolute favorite one Omar via Franca
CBS News Wiley Texas
all right ice cream is always worth it
go ahead have a bowl yourself tell him
Tony said it's okay that's our show I
hope it brightens your day I hope it
lifted you up in fact I know that it did
meantime I'm gonna go find some more
good news see you again soon
[Music]
everything
thank you